en ce début d'après midi l'allemagne est
donc toujours à la manoeuvre pour tenter
d'écarter tout risque de conflit à l'est
de l'europe olaf scholz est actuellement
en train de s'entretenir avec le
président russe vladimir poutine reçu au
kremlin de chancelier allemand était
d'ailleurs déjà à kiev en ukraine on va
retrouver tout de suite en direct de
berlin pour évoquer cette énième
initiative diplomatique pascal thibaux
bonjour on verra très vite ce qu'il
ressort de ce nouvel entretien mais il y
avait déjà avant la rencontre des signes
plutôt très positif
il ya eu quelques signes effectivement
qui donne des raisons d'espérer hier
c'était le ministre des affaires
étrangères russe lavrov qui disait en
répandant à vladimir poutine que cela
valait la peine qu'il y avait encore des
pistes de négociations avec les pays de
l'ouest et puis donc ce matin on
apprenait que quelqu un certain nombre
de troupes russes massés le long de la
frontière ukrainienne allait être
retirée immédiatement on entendait une
réaction à kiev affirmant qu' une à
risque d'intervention militaire russe
était écarté donc ce qu'on lisait
parfois dans les commentaires de la
presse allemande de ce matin plagiant le
célèbre livre de léon tolstoï et affirme
en guerre ou paix est peut-être
aujourd'hui - un raccourci peut être un
peu moins vrai puisque c'était une
référence bien entendu aux informations
selon lesquelles d'après les états unis
pour y avoir une intervention dès demain
en tout cas ce que veut olaf scholz et
bien c'est à la fois prouvé au kremlin
que l'otan l'europe sont unis et qu'il y
aurait des sanctions massives et
importante à l'égard de la russie si
l'intervention devait avoir lieu mais en
même temps plaidé pour une désescalade
trouvait également une voie pour la
discussion pour restaurer ou pour en
tout cas arrivé à une rencontre du
format normandie au niveau des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement peut être une
piste aussi pourrait être l'appartenance
ou plutôt la non appartenance de
l'ukraine à l'otan dont seule ça parlait
hier avec le président ukrainien à kiev
évoqué il ya quelques instants c'était
énième initiative
diplomatique olaf scholz qui marche dans
les pas des manuels macron qui procède à
peu près au même parcours la semaine
dernière quels sont les enjeux
aujourd'hui pour berlin
il ya une semaine après olaf scholz
profite peut-être j'évoquais l'unité
affichée par l'union européenne par
l'union européenne et les etats unis sur
ce dossier des très nombreuses
consultations qui ont eu lieu depuis la
visite d' emmanuel macron berlin avait
laissé la préséance en quelque sorte à
la france qui préside l'union européenne
l'allemagne a traditionnellement des
relations importantes pour des raisons
historiques et culturelles avec avec la
russie et veut de nouveau essayé de
proposer ses services de ses services de
bons offices en quelque sorte et
parvenir à maintenir le dialogue puisque
c'est avant tout la diplomatie la carte
qu'a voulu jouer l'allemagne depuis le
départ avec des critiques à l'encontre
de la façon dont l'allemagne se
positionnait contre les conséquences ou
non et où le fait qu'il y aurait ou non
des sanctions contre le fameux gazoduc
germano russe nord stream 2 le le refus
aussi de livrer des armes à l'ukraine a
été sévèrement critiqué pour l'allemagne
c'est la piste diplomatique liée à la
résolution de l'union européenne et au
delà des etats-unis qui doit pousser le
la russie à
renouer le dialogue pour tenter de
trouver une solution qui permette à
chacun de garder la face merci beaucoup
parce qu'elle